this program brought to you by Mercedes
AMG be prepared for whatever comes your
way the all-new GT 4-door coupe life is
a race visit your local dealership for a
test drive today Trey young me hawks
guard was voted unanimously the all-nba
rookie team's gonna have to wait a
little while to find out if he is the
Rookie of the Year and Trey back on the
program good morning Trey how are you
I'm doing good how you doing where are
you off to this weekend I'm heading to
Spain
later today let's go watch a soccer game
out there Madrid looking forward to it
well this is this is a big soccer game
soccer match it's going to be fine
are you a soccer player when you did you
play soccer growing up
I mean maybe when I was a kid I've been
little leave but I mean as I got around
seven eight years old I start I I was
never in soccer shape
you got to play that way you were in
basketball shape not soccer shoe yeah
yeah it's a different type different I I
read a lot of things about the role your
dad played in your development I mean
your your father did an awful lot of
great things for you whether it was
breaking down film or making sure you
got to see some of these great players
or great players reaching out to you
know give you tips how do you thank your
dad after all he's done for you I mean I
really can't thank him enough I mean
it's everything he's done for me I mean
early in my you career where he was
driving me an hour and a half two hours
just just to take me to practice and for
me to play on AAU teams and Dallas and
Kansas City and things like that so all
the little things you did for me I mean
I don't know if I can ever Pam for sure
what did you think first time you saw
Steve Nash play oh I mean he was my
favorite player before I even saw him
play just from watching him on TV but
but I got to see him live in Oklahoma
City was was crazy
I showed up hour and a half
[Laughter]
so watch them warm up no I wanted to see
everything he's he's been my favorite
player since I was a kid and nothing has
changed how do you emulate Steve Nash
it's not easy
no it's definitely not easy I don't
think each movie
I mean emulate him perfectly I mean I
tried to do a lot of the things he does
as far as like his off balance I mean
off balance shooting his touch things
like that and it's hard to emulate him
but I tried to the best I can't have you
gone to any basketball games during the
playoffs yeah yeah well I went to two
games I went to Game three of the
Portland welcome to the City game back
home in Oklahoma City and then I went to
the Rockets warriors Game three in
Houston what do you take away from your
wife Anne are you watching it as a
fellow player I mean it's definitely
different for me I I know I look at it
differently I mean just because I played
against two teams and like I know what's
coming I know the sets they're calling I
can I can hear I'll just look at the
things differently and I mean to be
honest that NBA playoffs atmosphere
there's something that I also notice and
it's not differently I mean the fans are
and how more engage they are little
things like that it's definitely
different and I just wanted to
experience it before I mean God will
we're in it so what's it like though
when you got James Harden with the ball
and you're out there on an island with
him you gotta you gotta ask for help you
know it's gonna be tough it's hard
guards I'm a one-on-one you guys try
your best and test and yeah make sure
you got help behind you all right is it
more helpless trying to guard harden or
Steph Curry
I think it is this is different like you
have to be aware of I mean help behind
you when you're going hard in making
sure you get a contest but when you're
guarding stuff you're always on the move
and you're always running as soon as you
relax best realizes it and then he keeps
moving and that's when he gives you so
it's just a different type of defense
and awareness for sure with both of them
so I can't really say which one is
harder we're talking to Trey young the
Atlanta Hawks guard and I remember the
first time I saw you and I came in I
think were you playing Portland OR
Portland State or this is at Oklahoma
did you put up like 44 in the game yeah
yeah okay but I saw you in a game where
I came in the next day or that was his
Saturday I think I came in on Monday and
I said boy this kid out Oklahoma has got
Steph Curry range
I made an unfair comparison to you with
Steph Curry because with the range and
you don't play like Steph Curry you're
you are more of a Steve Nash in my
opinion you're you're a great passer I
think that's what people forget they get
caught up in your shooting your range I
was more impressed with your passing and
and you don't find that with too many
guys today everybody loves to shoot but
you know when did you fall in love with
the past well I mean for me I think you
said watch the Steve Nash I mean I did a
bad job of missing that whenever you ask
me about about Steve because that's
something that I mean I took a lot of
pride in especially watching him with
his ability to discuss with the the the
right hand and the left hand so that's
something that there's a lot of pride in
and I love doing it just because I grew
up watching him toughest defender you
had this year was who are you going to
give him credit but I think clay was
very tough
Kawai guards me a lot throughout the
rest of the game what was that like it
was definitely definitely a I mean a
battle he's physical very very physical
you can tell right now and draw the play
off - yeah who's the best player in the
game I think I've given you the first
pick you got the first pick and I got
the second pick okay we're on the
playground you get first pick I get the
next - okay well I'm uh I'm out to go
with Katie hmm I like like Katie okay
with the first pick and now he's a
little injured so but that's an
advantage for me I'm gonna take Kauai
and LeBron hmm is my take now yeah you
know I'll have to go at odds go it's des
okay are you just taking the Warriors is
that what you're doing Trey will you
play basketball in Madrid when you're
there this weekend yeah I'll work out a
couple times so just you go to a
playground know what happened in the
shoe like you're shooting percentage in
the beginning of the season was not very
good and then it got really good so so
what happened I just think I just got
more comfortable I mean the speed and
the taste of the game and I was just
able to slow it down and relax a little
more I think early on I was rushing and
just trying to take out the the speed
and my me I just could never get into
rhythm I was always able to get to the
lane make my floaters that get layups
and get assists and say like that but my
threes is wasn't falling and later on it
was it changed so I think that was the
maintenance
you ever get down on yourself your first
year no no no never really just because
I know how hard I worked and and how I
mean how much I prepared I know it's all
gonna and so I'm gonna turn out good in
the end all right a couple of things you
got to work on in the off season I got
to get you a little bit stronger
I got a you know we got to play a little
more defense this year tre okay
but if you score more like Steph Curry
does then you don't have to play any
defense at all and James Harden guys
don't play defense do you think I could
score on Harden I do you get a score you
think so if I got if I got the ball ten
times against Harden do I score once I
haven't seen you play I would see me
play whether the jumpers wet right
that's all I mean that's I'm just gonna
say that jumpers wet not anybody I think
I could score on you at one time oh now
you're a lockdown defender you know what
when you get to Madrid just mention my
name and then they'll tell you they
remember yeah I put up a triple-double
on somebody over there yeah hey enjoy
the offseason it's not gonna last long
and safe travels over to Spain enjoy the
soccer and good luck when the
announcement rolls around you haven't
ice in an acceptance speech written for
Rookie of the Year not yet not yet are
you going to have one no I'll probably
have it all on the fly so that's going
to be something yet to talk about on the
slide well good luck with that great
season and we'll hopefully talk to you
again soon okay thank you
that's Trey young the Atlanta Hawks
guard for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]